N
UNEXPLAID PLOSIONS IN THALROA
ATTACKRO.
HAS MANYIES WITH ITSTHWEST
MOSTMPORTANTLY, ONMARCH TORD
WESTNI
IN FACT, IN TE JUNE,T GRTE CANDN
TODASS A
SE
I  TKNO AUGH AND THE.
D I HAD ANOR TO TALK PRIMER
TOE  THE SHOW.
LI UKRPART OF THE RUSSIA
SOVIET EMPIRE LY ARNCRACY.NDD.M
ALSO BEEN
PART OTWEEN THE T ANCOR.
RAUT WE ALSO
UKRAINIAN
BULGARIAN AN
ELECTIONS, PEOPLE
MASSIVELY FOR A PROEUREAMAJORIG
STITUTIONSFIGHPTN, ENSG R HUMANH
STVIN
INTEGRATIOE STATS BEEN A
GNOVA, T WAID R BUVERY UNFORTUNS
SA COMPLICATENTEXIN
TH SS E.
>> TELL WHA BEE
HT THEU SAY E
A PASSED THROUGH
DESCRIBEOI
>>ND
AROUND RLRP OF DED UKRAINE ANDE
VERY WI A AER NS AND THEE SOME
PLANS T OU WE T
COID THE
RY
E RE S MOBILIZED I
EMPLARY ANON RS MOVEUGA BUT ALS
HYPOTHETICALW  THE MITHER INTO N
COURSE,RY
WORRIED ESPECIALLYRING TROOPS OH
RYTHING POSS
TO MAINTAIN PEAND ITY
AN
DO ESCALATE.
>> FOR YOU, WHEN LOO
SITUATIO UE
WERE ABL THIS TH CONQUERED
E  2 WHAT KINDPUU
IN?
>> THIS IS AY DIFFICULT NT FOM
COY S ON RULES
RNATIONAL ORDER.
IF A CRT AN
WAR ANY U W
NOBODISD INK THAT A
A PY AL. ABL
CONTINUE TO DO
DO EVEN IF THERICE GOE
HIGHER, GE HIGHER?
MOLDOVA T AFCT
COAFTEINOMALROM THIS
WE SAW VER
TH JUNE WA
32%.
CONTINU A
THE GOVERNMENTA ARGO JUST PEOPL.
ALL ANYRICE GOE
RESILIEN THROUGH VERY,Y DIFFICUF
50%  RE